and finally America new rule America
does need to build a wall a seawall
because the ice is melting and rising
oceans are going to swallow Miami
hey Marco Rubio you're from there you're
the senator from Florida in 20 years
you're gonna be the senator from
Atlantis what is it with Republicans and
the environment they never waver in
their commitment to do nothing the
threat they see is a horde of rapey
terrorists poring over the southern
border here's a chart showing the trends
in apprehensions along our southern
border here's a chart showing the trend
in global carbon rise if you're not a
chart person let me summarize
carbon is killing us Mexicans are not
but ever since the 35 day silent
treatment
came to an end last week the master
negotiator has been threatening to play
his final card declaring a national
emergency
but Republicans don't want another
shutdown so they've come up with a
reason why they can't go along with that
here's what Rubio said about that if
today the national emergency is border
security tomorrow the national emergency
might be climate change yeah god forbid
we start declaring a national emergency
about something that's an actual
national emergency
the right-wing has a new boogie woman in
Alexandria Acacio Cortez and she is
being called a hysterical
not-ready-for-prime-time crazy lady
because she protested for a green new
deal outside of Nancy Pelosi's office
and also said the world is going to end
in 12 years if we don't address climate
change to which I say thank you it's
about time it's about time someone
framed the issue with the appropriate
level of urgency and when she cited 12
years that wasn't a number she just
pulled out of her ass like Trump does
she was referring to a timeline from the
UN's Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change and they say if we don't do a
reversal of current trends by 2030 it
will be too late now I don't agree with
that because 2030 is optimistic yeah
climate headlines in recent years have a
definite theme which is you know that
pants should in fact we told you a year
ago will [ __ ] more ocean warming is
accelerating faster than we thought
Antarctica's ice sheet is melting three
times faster than we thought climate
change driving species out of habitats
much faster than expected you see a
pattern but here's a glimmer a tiny
glimmer of hope Americans are starting
to get it 73% now believe global warming
is happening an increase of 10% from
four years ago and more than six and ten
now except that it's man-made half of
Americans say the science is more
convincing than it was five years ago
which is [ __ ] stupid but I'll take it
I'm placing muck thank you I'm placing
my hope in how mad people are going to
get when climate change starts killing
not just monarch butterflies and all the
bees and the whales but stuff much
closer to home we may be close to
killing maple syrup and wine in the
traditional wine regions of France Italy
and Napa Valley could all be too hot to
grow grapes by 2050 and then where will
alcoholics go on vacation with no more
mine men trying to impress their dinner
dates will have to burn money at the
table
priests will have to get children in the
mood with music
hotter hotter drier growing seasons also
make it harder to grow hops which makes
beer
what is Brett Kavanaugh get a drink with
squeak and coffee 60% of wild coffee
species are at risk of going extinct got
your attention now huh
without Starbucks we're our unemployed
screenwriters gonna sit around all day
where will Millennials get free Wi-Fi
where we find our next president and
look at this the banana as we know it is
dying I never thought this sentence
would make sense but yes we have no
bananas coffee bananas maple syrup we're
a breakfast item away from losing the
Grand Slam
you